this is the aftermath of peak wildfire
season in greece
in this picturesque town about 30
kilometers north of athens
there's an eerie quiet as people take
stock of what has been lost
hectares of land burned
and homes destroyed
24 year old ariavni lived in this house
her entire life with her family
on july 20th within the span of an hour
everything her family had was gone
so this was the living room
and here was a it was our
the table where we used to eat
ariuvani's family home is the only house
in this area that was destroyed
and there was a studio there with drums
and guitars this house is one of the
many homes in the country that is not
insured
according to the hellenic association of
insurance companies
only 15 percent of homes in greece have
insurance
no why not
because we didn't think that it would
happen to us
but it did so it can happen to anyone
that's not the only reason most people
here don't insure their homes
maria polansa owns one of the oldest and
biggest insurance agencies in athens
according to her agency's figures since
the wildfires started destroying homes
in the past two years
there has only been about a two to three
percent increase in insurance contracts
i think the main reason is that they
haven't understood how valuable their
property is only when they lose it they
understand and also they have not
realized how inexpensive it is to have
home insurance if they comprehend that
home insurance cost roughly one euro per
square meter per year i believe that
most greek people would consider
insuring their homes
one of the other main issues here is the
government has not been able to mandate
the purchase of home insurance
most properties in greece are passed on
through family inheritance so most
people don't have mortgages that means
they are not legally forced to purchase
home insurance
the government has tried to force
homeowners to buy insurance only in
certain parts of the country a move
which outraged the insurance companies
and forced it to abandon the idea but it
does provide some financial assistance
to those who have lost their homes to
natural disasters
for now many greeks remain uninsured and
face financial ruin with every fire
season
jabari al jazeera athens